the scenes of two foreign-policy
episodes from the Nixon and Ford
administration's the Yom Kippur War of
1973 and the end of the Vietnam War in
1975 he spoke about it for about an hour
I assume these microphones are working
and we'll get right down to business the
book that we're going to be talking
about is crisis the anatomy of two major
foreign policy crises by Henry Kissinger
this is and rework your tenth book or
and then closer to the 1515 busy busy
busy
what I'm going to do since four-fifths
of this book is about the Middle East
crisis of 1973 which we have come to
call the Yom Kippur War that's most of
this book the tail end of it the last
hundred pages have to do with the
extrication of the United States from
the at Nam and because Kissinger's last
book was getting out of Vietnam I'm
going to take the liberty of not dealing
with it but if you want to ask questions
about Vietnam that's your business you
can do that I would like to to deal with
the Middle East for a couple of reasons
one that we're all in the Middle East
right now and particularly after this
extraordinary weekend the capture of
Saddam Hussein let me just give you the
briefest synopsis of this of his crisis
two weeks after Kissinger became
Secretary of State on October 6 1973
which happened to be Yom Kippur the
holiest day in the Jewish calendar Egypt
and Syria launched a a coordinated
attack against Israel opening what came
to be called the Yom Kippur War the u.s.
became deeply involved sort of the
Soviet Union a superpower confrontation
quickly followed the Russians supplied
the Arabs the u.s. supplied Israel
finally due in large measure to the
energetic diplomacy of Henry Kissinger
backed by President Nixon on October
28th 1973 for the first time in in a
quarter of a century Egypt and Israel
did sit down for direct talks and less
than five years later
was a peace treaty signed between Israel
and Egypt and that October of 1963 was
an extraordinary month because President
Nixon was absorbed with the Watergate
crisis the Saturday night massacre he
faced the monkey business of a vice
president named Spiro Agnew and found
that he had to get rid of him and in his
place he had to move in Gerald Ford dr.
Kissinger in the meantime was picking up
a Nobel Peace Prize for his negotiating
work on Vietnam I mean it was a busy
time and we all learned a great deal
okay let's get down to work on a crisis
of this sort in the Middle East would
pose many challenges for you many
opportunities for you at the same time
tell us a little bit about the the
challenges and then the opportunities
that you sought to derive from them well
the first challenge we had was to find
out what was going on because I learned
about the crisis when Joe Cisco who was
under secretary for political affairs
awakened me I was in New York for the UN
and he said there's some trouble in the
Middle East and if you get honored right
away you can get it under control
he was wildly optimistic so I tried at
the war had not yet started it was about
to start we I had a message waiting for
me from the Israeli prime minister
asking me to assure the Arab such that
Israel had no intention of attacking
them so that if any of their
preparations for an attack were caused
by an attempt to forestall the Israelis
that would not be necessary I could not
find any Syrian to talk to it all they
were answering their telephone I found
the Egyptian Foreign
understood who also was without
instructions I woke up the Soviet
ambassador to Brennan who either was
sleepy or was also instructed not to
facilitate things one or the other
I finally got so impatient that I said
to him if it keeps up the war will be
over before you understand what I'm
saying and by the way by the way forgive
me this book is a is 95 percent a
collection of telephone scripts of
telephone conversations the dr.
Kissinger had a Secretary of State with
all of the foreign ministers the
ambassadors the president plays Henrico
but anyway we assembled the crisis
management group that normally met in
Washington I I was still in New York and
the first conclusion of the crisis
management group was that the Israelis
had attacked because they could not
conceive that the Arab that Arab states
would attack when all our estimates had
always been that they would truly be
defeated if they did attack now I was
absolutely convinced that it was
inconceivable that the Israelis would
attack without mobilization on Yom
Kippur when most of them were in
synagogue and when we had not seen any
preparations for any kind of military
move but it it took until about 10:30 it
took four hours before we were clear
that it was an Egyptian and Syrian
attack on Israel which you had not
really anticipated well what had
happened was was that I had not in
general anticipated it but when I became
sacred when I became Secretary of State
when I was sworn in two weeks earlier I
found that
in the organization chart that the State
Department had an Intelligence Group of
which I was not aware so I came in on
the first Saturday after I was sworn in
but a week later lithium and read some
of their reports some of their raw
reports just to see what they were
producing and there was one report that
said there are Egyptian troop
concentrations on the sewers and Syrian
troop concentration on the :
and so I I was concerned about that
enough to ask the CIA and the Israelis
what they knew
they both said yet their troop
concentrations they doesn't mean
anything they're on maneuvers and so I
asked every every two days I asked him
to update me so I was concerned enough
to be informed but not concerned enough
to do something because and in turn they
that's they were taking in each other's
washing I mean CIA and the Israelis were
in close contact with each other and I
think it's safe to say that the Israelis
did not want to alarm us unduly because
they were afraid we might start some
diplomatic initiative prematurely but be
that as it may the two weeks between my
being sworn in and the beginning of the
war we were watching things but in
intelligence it isn't just what you know
it's the questions you asked we did not
ask the right questions we did not ask
why it's how is it possible that the
Egyptians and Syrians who do not get
along
having exercises along the line
simultaneously then on the Thursday
before the war started we learned that
the Soviets
who had a substantial military
establishment in Egypt and no who had
had a substantial but who had a lot of
civilians still civilian technicians
still in Egypt and also many in Syria
were withdrawing all their dependents
again we asked intelligence what does
that mean and we got the answer well
this means there's some quarrel between
the Arabs and the Soviets and we had
seen that before but again we should
have asked the question what kind of
quarrel could take place between Moscow
and Egypt and Syria simultaneously since
those two anyway we didn't ask those two
questions in retrospect I think the
Soviets was true their dependence in
part to give us a warning that a war was
about to start but we were surprised and
this Raley's were surprised and from
then on the question was there were two
questions three questions how should we
conduct what influence should we try to
take on the military operation secondly
what diplomacy should we adopt answered
how much and when should we help Israel
with military supplies we started from
the assumption that Israel would win
very quickly we also started with a
conviction that we wanted to use that
opportunity to want to use this crisis
as an opportunity to begin a negotiating
process in the Middle East in which we
would emerge as the key country because
we were in touch with all the parties
and my team to the Arab side was all
through the war you're making war with
Soviet arms but you'll have to make
peace with American diplomacy and so we
were in AIT's complicated situation
where on the one side we wanted Israel
to win to defeat Soviet arms but we also
wanted to do if it happened in a way
where we could retain our influence in
the Arab world and where we would reduce
the influence of the Soviet Union so we
had several balls in the air
simultaneously Henry if I may interrupt
there you did have many balls in here at
the same time and it was very difficult
to pull this all off you were on the
phone according to this book with the
Israeli ambassador with the president
with hey what scope roughed with the
Russians what's Cali up at the UN you
were the central figure and you ended up
being the central figure even for the
Russians at a certain point just before
the Saturday night massacre you were
invited by Brezhnev to go to Moscow and
you use that as a 72-hour opportunity to
give the Israelis an opportunity to
improve their military position which
would then improve your diplomatic
ability to try to pull off some kind of
an agreement how does that work and well
if I may may tell an anecdote hopefully
in that connection you accurately
describe what the strategy was by the
end of the second week it was clear that
the Israelis were winning and the
Soviets came to us and I welcomed an
opportunity to go to Moscow because that
meant there would be a 48 to 72 hour
delay and I wanted to string it out long
enough to improve our bargaining
when when I arrived in Moscow it was
Saturday evening and I said I have to go
to bed after well they said kreshnik
wants to have a social meeting with you
so at midnight I went to the Kremlin and
I had already had a dinner at the state
guesthouse I'd eat another dinner with
Brezhnev Rich's never lost all the
weight I gained that at another dinner
with freshness and he said you know
tomorrow we've got to settle it and I'd
be a serious and I said yes real serious
but you have to understand that I'm only
the secretary of state I have to check
all of this with President Nixon so you
have to have understanding for this and
president said no you don't have to
check it with President Nixon he sent me
a telegram this afternoon giving me full
giving you full powers you have full
authority and he had handed me the
telegram well I went back to the state
gets out and I had an open line which
certainly their essence we're listening
in on but I was at I had lost my hours
lost my temper to such a degree that I
was yelling at Haig on the telephone
which was it was not uncharacteristic of
me together it was uncharacteristic of
me to complain about having too much
power
so I kept going on to Hague how could
you do this how could you send such a
telegram and The Hague was chief of
staff to Nixon at the time so Hague said
to me will you get off my back I have
problems of my own and I said what
problems can you have in Washington on a
Saturday night
and then he told me and then I knew we
really we really had problems also in
Moscow because whatever authority I had
depended on the authority of the
president and when that slips then the
negotiators authority slips to everyone
I want to ask you a couple of questions
about about Watergate one of the things
that you say here and you make a big
point about that is that Watergate began
to corrode your capacity to conduct
foreign policy and you were very
concerned and it comes up in any number
of conversations in the book at one
point Haig says that the president wants
to make an announcement and he wants to
make the announcement in prime time that
you are going off to Moscow and you said
I think quote my honest opinion is that
it's a cheap stunt it looks as if he is
using foreign policy to cover a domestic
thing and and Hague says I don't see it
as a contrived phony I think you have
two very interesting things happening in
other words the Saturday night massacre
and Kissinger going off and you will
regret it you say for the rest of your
life it will forever after they said he
did this to cover Watergate but he would
say as you the debate concerning
Watergate at that moment was about
whether the phone conversations of the
not the phone carrier agency the taping
a thing of all of the clip saving of all
of the conversation should be turned
over to the Watergate investigating
committee and Nixon invoked executive
privilege and the matter had not yet
gone to the Supreme Court but what Nixon
proposed at that moment was said senator
Stennis and I think one or two others
should read the relevant tapes and make
a summary of them and make a report to
the envy
- gating committee so that not every
conversation had to be made public which
actually I thought was a reasonable
proposal I was not involved ever in any
of these discussions regarding Watergate
the same die day that Nixon made that
compromise with Stennis I was going to
go to Moscow and I had an additional
complication that I had early accepted
an invitation from the Chinese
ambassador and so I wanted to go to the
Chinese embassy first and then go to
Moscow I was a Chinese dinner on a
Friday night you're going to leave after
midnight and I want to leave after
midnight also because I wanted to arrive
in Moscow too late to begin negotiations
so is to gain another 12 hours well
anyway this debate concerns the
following the idea was that Nixon should
step out announced its tenets compromise
and announced my trip to Moscow and I
took violent objection to that as you
correctly read because I thought that
would link Watergate to the negotiations
in Moscow and I thought it would then
look at your foreign policy was being
used and so I felt very strongly and I
prevailed that they announced the
stennis compromise separately and that
after I had left for Moscow they
announced my having left for Moscow from
the White House the Saturday night
Massacre occurred because the prosecutor
who was Archibald Cox would not accept
this then his compromise and then Nixon
fired him and and that led to the
resignation of Elliot Richardson and
then to the resignation of his deputy
and that complex of events came to be
known as the Saturday night massacre and
your view at the time which I found very
interesting
was that Nixon I'll just reach what you
told hey I don't think they would have
taken on a functioning president this is
you're talking now about the Soviet
Union moving possibly moving forces in
to the Middle East and this was
something that was terribly important
terribly significant and you say I don't
think they would have taken on a
functioning president don't forget that
is what the Soviets are playing on they
find a [ __ ] facing impeachment and
why shouldn't they go in there there was
you already know that's new
no but that wasn't that night nope it
was later but this was October 24th yeah
this was this was after you were already
been alive sequence was after the
Saturday night massacre then impeachment
proceedings started as a reaction to
decided in the discussion of impeachment
as a possibility yeah well actually they
began moving taking the first steps
towards it in the house they add you're
suggesting here three days afterward
that Nixon is no longer a functioning
president well because you're describing
as a [ __ ]
well what happened that week was I went
to Moscow we negotiated a ceasefire
agreement
I went from Moscow to Tel Aviv and we
were sort of naive
we flew right parallel to the combat
zone and we'd send a message to the
Sixth Fleet that they should pick us up
along the way and escort us and Admiral
Murphy who was in command and told me
afterwards they were going crazy how do
you find a single plane coming out of
the Jovian Union flying parallel to the
combatant and they finally picked us up
near Cyprus and well at any rate so we
went to Israel and
induced them to accept if he fire then
they then I flew back from Israel to
washing now it's Monday morning arrived
in washing with newspaper headlines
president's impeachment is being talked
about and after a few hours sleep I get
to the office and I find that the
Israelis had summed off again and jumped
off again head had started military
operations again and the they told us
they it were attacked but they were
being in fact they were advancing the
whole time but and they trapped the
Egyptian Third Army so and all of this
was happening while the Nixon was
severely preoccupied with a Saturday
night Massacre crisis and and then a
point was reached with it Soviet Union
seemed to us to be mobilizing their
Airborne Division's and a threatening
letter was received and I don't remember
every conversation but it must have been
in that context that I said they would
never have dared to do this word not for
the fact that it not for the fact that
they're facing a president who is
confronting impeachment yeah and and the
words that you use just it strikes me on
on reading it now and then putting
yourself back to 1973 that you yourself
were deeply concerned that the man you
were working for the president United
States was a [ __ ] and incapable of
being a functioning president now in
other in other conversations you say
that you're in crises mix that in fact
in other conversations in this book you
say that in fact during crises when you
were talking to Nixon he was very
clear-headed and very strong laureate
precise no there was no Nixon
had extraordinary knowledge about
foreign policy and he was essentially
extremely decisive but he had to spend a
good deal of his physical time simply on
the legal requirements of Watergate and
a good deal of his emotional time and he
still had so much prestige around the
world for the decisiveness with which he
had acted in the previous years that it
did not impair us as much as you would
think from studying political science
textbooks but it was my nightmare
constantly and every time we made a
decisive move we were faced with
answering the question are you doing
this in order to protect the president
was the president doing it to protect
himself from Watergate let me be very
precise about what you have just said
there's a wonderful book that was put
out in 1974 it's the first serious
biography of dr. Kissinger done by
Bernard calve and myself Barack help is
right here delighted that you are here
and and I want to give you the flavor of
this and give you the flavor of
Kissinger's answer mr. secretary I asked
could you tell us whether the United
States received a specific warning from
the Soviet Union that it would send its
forces unilaterally into the Middle East
do you have intelligence that the
Russians are preparing for such an
action the reason I raise these
questions as you know there has been
some line of speculation this morning
that the American alert the u.s. had up
at the alert status of military forces
as preparation and as a signal to the
Soviet Union that the American alert
might have been prompted as much perhaps
by American domestic requirements as by
the real requirements of diplomacy in
the Middle East and I wonder if you
could provide some additional
information on that to which dr.
Kissinger replied Marvin
they are attempting to no I don't we are
attempting to conduct the foreign policy
of the United States with regard for
what we own not just to the electorate
but to future generations it is a
symptom of what is happening to our
country that it could even be suggested
that the United States would alert its
forces for domestic reasons we do not
think it was at this moment to go into
the details
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh but that that
apparently became the cause of a
conversation that you had with Nixon
where when 346 he got the I mean he was
really most distressed by what was going
on here and and you said in this
conversation they will carry it was the
idea that the president would have a
news conference you said they will carry
it I will explain it it at the press
conference these sob zits all gentlemen
are saying we did all of this for
political purposes Nixon I know like Cal
and who else
Kissinger Cal McCarthy Breaston called
here with similar questions and then you
say I treated kelp contemptibly at the
press conference
then you go on I would treat the
bastards with contempt mr. president
they asked me about Watergate Kissinger
mr. president you were prepared to put
forces in and that was way before you
knew what was going to happen
I told Cal that the president is
attempting to conduct foreign policy
United States regardless blah blah blah
Nixon good al told me al hey told me you
slaughtered the bastards keep it up
Kissinger that is what I am here for
keep it up Nixon said we will survive no
question Henry what I mean I'm shocked
absolutely shocked there's gambling at
the White House
what why were you so upset that a
reporter would ask you a question about
this and why were you feeding Nixon with
these lines that you know you've got to
treat the bastards with contempt why
well you have to remember this we had
been through two weeks three weeks of
non-stop crisis that was a week that had
started in Moscow as I described we had
barely come back when a new crisis
started where we were practically every
night
the Israelis having trapped a third army
after the ceasefire had been made and we
were pretty convinced that the Soviet
Union could not tolerate the destruction
of an Egyptian army after a ceasefire
that had been negotiated in Moscow and
signed by the Soviet leader then
Wednesday night we received a message
from Brezhnev saying we should both sent
forces into the Middle East and ending
by saying I must speak to you frankly
that was something close to that if you
do not follow we will act
naturally I've detected here was that
directness Fidesz it that was in effect
so we assembled the National Security
Council and began to deliberate and I
called over
I called Dupree Ninh Soviet ambassador
and said don't act until you hear from
us now he could have said what are you
talking about of course we won't act
until we hear from you that's why I
communicated with you he kept saying I
will report this to Moscow this happened
two or three times at the same time we
noticed that don't hold me to these
exact numbers but the proportions are
right that ten of the twelve Soviet
Airborne Division's
were grounded which means they were
being assembled four for action and we
were watching every airplane that flew
that fluid south to see whether this
this was the beginning of it so we
decided that before we would send an
answer we would raise the alert of
military forces one not because set
generates a lot of activity by cable a
lot of movement people get called in
from leave but it's not there five
levels of preparedness and level one is
war level two it's you get enclosed we
moved to level three from from level
four so the Soviets would notice a lot
of military type activity before they
received our answer and we then we then
send send our answer so then at the end
of all of that to be asked whether we
did it all in order to help a president
in his domestic difficulties
more than my nervous system for that
they could stand Henry what at one point
fascinated in the page 3:30 in your book
you threatened when the Israelis tried
to conduct their policy in a way they
considered in their best interests you
lost your cool you were upset with them
and you threatened quote a total
reevaluation of America's relations with
Israel you made the same threat also on
a background ER in the Middle East in
April of 1975 there was almost two years
later what and I've always been I've
always wanted to it what would that have
meant what would you mean by a total
reevaluation of US relations with Israel
I mean were you kidding I forget in what
context that was this was in the same
context of the Israelis trying to move
into the to the Egyptian Third Army and
one of course the one that's undefended
I was conducting the foreign policy of
the United States right and certainly
the Israelis were conducting policy in
their perception of their national
interest right but we had just run and
an airlift of putting the entire
American air lift at the disposal of a
small country which is not the usual
procedure we had negotiated the
ceasefire and we were maintaining the
airlift even after the ceasefire so what
precisely it would have meant it really
doesn't matter so much I was trying to
convey to dinner that there was a limit
beyond which we could not support them
and this is one aspect of diplomacy if
you have other conversations
I mean Dennis's shred of it was
he himself was not talking to any
senator he did not God forbid that he
would talk to us Iraq you lessly they
learn but miraculously they always so he
held in reserve his army in hundreds
that he thought he had and but the
essence is that considering what was at
stake for both countries survival for
Israel for America our position in the
Middle East and our capacity to conduct
a major policy that on on the whole the
conversations were not conducted with
Reds they were conducted on a very
simple manner no but they had a phrase
jumped out at me because you would used
it later
mostly later President Ford you did but
certainly I agreed with it I was just
wondering what how would the United
States
act toward Israel were there a total
reevaluation of policy or were you
simply trying to threaten his go to the
survival of Israel would always remain
an American fundamental objective but
within that framework the degree of
cooperation could be adjusted but we
never reached that point so I can't tell
you exactly okay what we had one with we
would have had in mind what I was trying
to convey to it two tenets was we had
gone through an alert we had gone
through the world we could not have a
crisis every night and we could not be
facing a situation in which then they
had to understand that they could not
destroy the tsunami I was all the more
convinced of this because I did not
think that is drawing the Third Army
would do Israel any good it would have
probably led to the collapse of Sadat it
would have brought a radical into power
in in Cairo it might have brought the
Soviets in into the field and so I was
trying to
conveyed to the Israelis that there was
a limit beyond which it couldn't go and
once they understood this and accepted
it we used it to get the Egyptians to
produce a negotiator by telling Egypt
that we had gone as far as we could as a
mediator and they had to produce a
negotiator today that's it's taken for
granted but this was the first time that
an Arab and Israeli met face to face it
was also the first time that they
invited a Secretary of State to come to
Egypt and to begin a negotiation and
that sort of a start the Russians
exactly it led to a total reversal of
Egyptian foreign policy which had been
oriented to a towards Russia practically
as an ally and then shifted to the
United States to reliance on the United
States before we go to questions dr.
Castillo is wondering what is the
biggest lesson that that you feel you
learned in that three weeks of
incredibly intense diplomacy I mean even
as you look back upon it now well the
importance of having a strategic plan at
the beginning of the crisis the it's one
of the important lessons and we had a
strategic plan actually the the trouble
in the crisis is when you see
newspaper accounts of a crisis or not
newspaper cut movie accounts you see
people running around picking up
telephones yelling in to them that isn't
usually what happens usually it gets
very quiet and a lot of people sit in
foxholes and throw out an occasional
memo that they are not responsible for
for whatever is going on and there are
few people who are willing we are
willing to act but it is the hardest
thing is to find out what is going on so
if the more you can sink through what
you're trying to achieve ahead of time
the better your of and the less of your
time you then have to devote to to being
driven to being driven by events was was
what worked out ultimately what you had
in mind from the very beginning was that
your planned or did you have to adjust
the plan to development the reversal of
alliances that was part of the plan and
at some point out we communicated with
set out on the first day of the war and
then every other day practically
thereafter the tactics had to be
adjusted from day to day because for one
thing it really did not win it quickly
as we thought it would and so we had to
reverse really what our original
original idea was to ask people to ask
the armies to go back to where the war
had started which we thought would be a
position that might be attractive to the
Arabs after they had been defeated but
they weren't defeated very quickly it
took about two weeks before so we had to
adjust our thinking on that issue I just
want to say that you know as your PR man
for the book tonight that there was also
wonderful funny lines in this book that
you don't associate somehow with the
seriousness of the diplomacy at hand
at one point Kissinger is having a
conversation with the US ambassador to
the UN John Scalia former journalist
and Scalli had just come from a
discussion with Malik who was the Soviet
UN Ambassador and Kissinger says I have
just talked to Varun so and given him
our proposal you tell Malik to hold his
water meaning Malik was going to rush
forward with a proposal at the UN just
as you tell Malik to hold his water or I
will send him to Siberia
I know Brezhnev better than he does ask
him if he has ever been kissed on the
mouth by Brezhnev as I have anyway both
of them I'm making a maniac faith there
are some questions here from the
audience and let me get right to that
do you wish you were Secretary of State
today
and what would you do differently no I
it's a totally different situation
domestically and and internationally and
I'm happy as an observer and commentator
I haven't made a mistake since I'm a
commentator
after negotiations are complete
do you ever retain any relationship with
some of our adversaries ladakh toe for
example and others well I tell you Leduc
toe was an emotional experience he was a
representative of a small country that
had only one objective to break our
spirit they had one objective which was
to unify Vietnam and he had done nothing
except be a revolutionary I've visited
Hanoi after the agreement was made and
he took me around and we looked at a map
of Vietnam and every city he mentioned
he had been in some prison and I got a
terrific - that way of the pros and cons
of various prisons in Vietnam so I
respected him greatly because he was
disciplined he he was focused he never
lost his composure and he was very
clever but with him I had no
overwhelming desire to go through that
meat grinder
you know you described the Israeli
sometimes as being as quote obnoxious as
the Vietnamese yes did they have a sense
of humor who the VIII attorney is really
yes sir help ease no I enjoyed the
entrails but the Israelis the Israeli
domestic situation is so complicated
that they cannot make their concessions
unless they can prove to themselves and
to their cabinet that they have got the
last drop of blood out of the stone at
least that's how it was in
I did so every negotiation as you know
travelling with me went to the last
second of the last hour of the last day
and I remember on our Syrian negotiation
I had sort of gives nod and you told me
about 24 hours given another shot
it's right it is yet going to work and
it did so that was a grueling experience
but I had great sympathy for the
Israelis because it's one thing for us
we are thousands of miles away to do
suggest attachments and make proposals
but the Israelis have a very narrow
margin of survival there and and they
can't afford many mistakes or any
mistakes so even when I was exasperated
by the process all the Israeli leaders
with whom I dealt were friends then and
remained friends the rest of my of their
lives and my land we did things you wish
complicate your life a secretary stay
being true it's complicated my situation
fertile because it when when you have
lived in a country that that perpetrated
the Holocaust you can't forget this and
it complicated it from the Israeli point
of view because if they was Secretary of
State has agreed with them that was
understandable but if a Jewish Secretary
of say disagreed with them that was
harder to take so it gave an edge to
disagreements Golda Meir handled it well
some once an American Jewish person said
to her but I don't like about Kissinger
said he's an American first Secretary of
State second and a Jew third and she
said doesn't bother me I read from right
to left
the question that I have here is is
prefaced with this I asked this question
with respect and historical curiosity
please explain what was behind your
quote pieces at hand comment just before
the 1972 election since subsequent
events demonstrated the piece was not at
hand at least for some years to come in
Vietnam no a piece I'll explain the
context in a minute piece was at hand in
the sense that the piece I was talking
about which was the agreement that was
under discussion was in fact completed
eight weeks later so then the question
is it's at hand is eight weeks
compatible with at hand but one can't
look at it from this point of view let
me give you the context and then you
decide how how valid this was we had
been negotiating for for nearly four
years under conditions of near Civil War
in the United States and I would get to
a meeting and I would say this is our
last position and let's say come on now
senator so-and-so and says oh they've
already said you should go to the next
position and and then we would be beaten
to death that we had somehow in the
media that we had missed an opportunity
and the Vietnamese were extremely
skillful at playing on this at one point
they put out publicly
I think publicly a 7-point proposed and
privately they gave me a nine-point
proposal so I said which one do you want
to negotiate
they said the nine-point proposal
privately so we negotiate the nine
points privately in they're beating us
to death why don't you answer the seven
points in New York Times beats us to
death and the Washington Post
so finally Nixon went public and
revealed everything so for about a week
everything was quiet then the Vietnamese
put out two explanatory points and all
hell broke loose again why don't you
answer the doing planet or report so
when it was all over I said to Lee
doctor tell me what exactly did the two
explanatory pawns explain they said
nothing we needed two points so we put
them out so this went on for four years
so on October 6 1972 they suddenly
accepted the last proposals that Nixon
had made publicly on may 8th of that
year dates don't matter so we went into
a crash negotiation and those proposals
no matter what people say today we're
far better than anything that had ever
been seen before and that anybody
thought possible so we worked literally
we negotiated 22 hours at a stretch for
three days and completed that agreed
completed then we then we traveled to
Saigon and we improved on the way we
kept sending new conditions to the North
Vietnamese and they accepted those
that's South Vietnamese for
understandable reasons it came to
suddenly the everything we had put
forward had been approved by the South
Vietnamese but they didn't think the
North Vietnamese would accept it so then
when the North Vietnamese accepted it it
was a a very difficult position for the
South Vietnamese so they poked I had to
come back and my problem in holding the
press conference was that I wanted to
convey that we wanted some more
negotiation because we could not end the
war by simply instead
imposing a settlement on the people with
whom he had fought but I wanted to tell
the South Vietnamese that there was a
limit to do a negotiation and so and I
wanted to convey what had happened so
this was again at the end of a grueling
period and I stepped out if I had had a
long time to prepare this I might have
chosen a happier phrase and then peace
is at hand but actually if you read that
press conference you will see it was
about what was it two hours it was a
very long press conference I went
through every provision of the agreement
the Vedas is described it makes it sound
as if I came out behind a curtain
set pieces at hand and ducked back
behind the curd I went through every
provision of the agreement so everybody
could figure out for himself and I wound
up that press conference by saying we
will not make an agreement until the
conditions are right but we will not be
stopped from an agreement when the
conditions are right that was the theme
I wanted to convey it was described at
the time as an election maneuver Nixon's
position throughout that period was he
would have preferred not to negotiate
because he thought he had such an
overwhelming majority he could only
disturb his conservative constituency
and the people who were for McGovern he
couldn't win over anyway so he was not
eager but he kept telling me I don't
need it I don't particularly want it at
this period but if you can get it we owe
it to ourselves and to the country to do
it and all these these conversations in
the Oval Office
out now on these subjects and all the
memos I wrote to the president and his
answers and you will see so that is what
we attempted to do we were concerned and
almost exclusively I would say
exclusively with the foreign
implications we try to keep these
parties together and and get another
negotiation started I did not think it
would take 8 weeks and I was too
optimistic okay um you know you don't
have much time
and I'd like to ask a couple of
questions about the Middle East now one
question what do you feel the judgment
of history will be on the invasion of
Iraq by the u.s. of course it depends
how it ends yeah okay that good good oh
I think that you know it's I mean if you
want to go that far that's all right but
it did I I was in favor of it and I
think that if it failed but it will be a
catastrophe and we have no choice except
to succeed okay
should the 9/11 Commission see the
president's Daily Brief for a summary
what do you think that that important
unless there are things in there now
dead burned in there and when I throw it
regularly I it's not a question of what
secret
what secrets would be revealed I think
the question is whether the president
whether that one should reveal the way
the president's intelligence is handled
and I don't see why having two or three
people read it which is what they have
agreed to and report to the other
commissioners and since these people
represent both parties I think that's a
satisfactory solution the US government
wants free elections and democratic
governance
the middle-east if we get democratic
governments are these governments likely
to work with the US or against the US
that's a very good question in the short
term in some countries it's very
possible that they are hostile to the
United States and I think it's important
to permit some historical evolution in
some of these situations you know a
spinoff on that question in your
judgment given all of the time that you
spent running in and out of the Middle
East and around the Middle East do you
think that most of the government's
there are capable have it within them
have the culture to develop democracy
democracy developed over hundreds of
years in the rest and if you would were
to look at the specific conditions in
the West that produced democracy you
would have to mention the reformation
mm-hmm so that there was no monolithic
church but in the West to begin with the
church had already insisted on a
separation in which the truth the church
could define what was just so the state
never had the absolute power over
justice but you would have to say that
information have to say the
Enlightenment after say capitalism the
Age of Discovery none of these
conditions have yet existed in this
combination in the Islamic cultures now
it doesn't mean that everything has to
follow exactly the same sequence but
when you have a monolithic religion and
no separation between church and state
and no pluralism it is very much more
difficult to get democracy and therefore
in
Turkey it's really the only Arab cannot
an Arab country based on a country in
that region where where democracy has
developed and also there's a phenomenon
that where there are democratic
elections what emerges is so-called
Islamic Republic's so this is a problem
we need to face on the other hand we
cannot stand for anything other than
democracy would also be going to stand
for and how to reconcile our aspirations
with the possibilities it's going to be
one of the huge challenges of
statesmanship and it seems that that
President Bush believes deep down and I
think honestly Hannah - this is
something that the Arab world can do and
can't do within a period of a brief but
he said my he certainly believed fitted
it's his obligation as president of the
United States to put it forward and that
it is not his right to say which country
can Israel is not ready for democracy my
guess is that in practice he's willing
to adjust to a slower process but he has
a great sense of responsibility about
the moral basis of our foreign policy
okay well we're out of time
and what do we do at this point give it
back to the Smithsonian I think anyway
Henry thank you very very much
and this
and this list
crisis is Henry Kissinger's 15th book
it's published by